these women call themselves the silence
breakers a group comprising of rapist
Harvey Weinstein's many accusers the
balance of power is now survivors in
Silence breakers ten abusers and
predators zero even a man as powerful
and famous as Weinstein will be held
accountable for their abuse of women
celebrating the watershed moment he was
convicted and they say the scales of
justice were rebalanced it would have
been great if he was convicted on on all
counts but just the fact that he got two
of them shows me that we are as a
society rising up you know and we can
make a difference Harvey Weinstein left
a New York Court yesterday in an
ambulance after being found guilty of
rape in the third degree and criminal
sexual assaults his fall from grace
means he faces a lengthy prison sentence
the legacy of his conviction it's hopes
will be lasting change in the industry
something a listers Kristin Scott Thomas
and Sharon Hagen believe is happening
but slowly I think we feel fast safer
than we felt for a long time the people
who who make the decisions still I mean
you know in charge of the studios or the
ones who control the purse strings or
are still predominantly males and that
until that sort of changes until that
landscape sort of diversifies a bit I
think they're still gonna be a bit of
trouble but yes it is Inc it's there's a
huge difference it's just important that
no one takes their foot off the pedal
because it could easily easily sit back
it needs to get further than the people
who go on television yeah look
attractive talking about it you know
yeah yeah it has to be it has to it has
to be something that is so
well-established in all industries in
all walks of life that that it becomes
then that you know then then will have
gained ground properly and campaigners
believe more women will now be
encouraged by Weinstein's guilty verdict
it's like a lightning rod and what it
does is that it now has empowered many
women from all sorts of different
sectors whatever their positions are to
feel
phidian's that they can raise their
voice so Weinstein's conviction is
vindication for his victims and could
enact real change in the industry and
beyond
Lucy Casa Sky News